what's good everybody my name is chef
tiana g i'm here with obizi and we're
bringing presidential bites to the cocoa
butter channel
first of all let's talk about how obama
was the swaggiest president we have ever
seen right i'm talking about from the
way he dressed because the music he
listened to
to the food he ate so that's why this
recipe that i'm recreating is absolutely
amazing i'm going to be recreating a
dish made by my mentor marcus samuelson
that obama had during his presidency
obviously we all love obama we're going
through this whole thing right now with
[Applause]
i don't even want to speak on that but
make sure you guys vote
your voice counts but on a lighter note
this recipe we're about to get into
is amazing so for the ingredients today
we're going to be using some boneless
short ribs you guys can use
english cut or flanking cut feel how you
feel do what you got to do
then we're going to be using mirepoix
which is carrots
onions and celery for the aromatics
today i have
ginger garlic lemongrass bay leaf
thyme and parsley and we also have a
little bit of fresh horseradish for the
braising liquid
we're going to be using beef stock red
wine
soy sauce and plum sauce
all right you guys so now that we have
went over the ingredients we're going to
start by taking our short ribs and
patting them
so they're dry because if we don't dry
them then they're going to hit the pan
and they're going to be wet and they're
going to stick to the bottom and we
don't want that at all
so just lightly pat the short ribs once
we do that we're going to season them
very generously with some salt and
pepper on both sides
when i say generous i mean generous we
seasoned things over here all right
i have my cast iron getting hot over
here so that's gonna be ripping hot when
we
add the short ribs i'm gonna add some
fresh cracked
pepper always fresh don't use the ground
pepper please just don't do that once
there's season
i'm going to go ahead and add my oil
into my pot and you want to see it
shimmer like that you want to make sure
the pot is really hot because
what we're doing right now is we're
browning the short rib
this is a key essential step in cooking
these obesity short ribs presidential
level here okay make sure you guys take
the time to do the steps correctly and i
don't want to overcrowd the pan
right away so i'm doing maybe like five
at a time
they're gonna cook like two minutes on
each side and then we're gonna flip them
over
smells great in here so far so
once i see a little bit of browning i'm
going to go ahead and flip them over
you don't want to cook them through you
just want to make sure you develop a
crust on each side
so pretty much what we're doing is
developing what we call fond
which is the good bits that gets stuck
to the bottom of the pan
and when we deglaze it that's what's
going to help build this amazing
flavor so not too long on each side
maybe like two minutes
and then once you get a nice browning on
all of the sides you want to transfer it
over into
like a sheet tray but i'm using this pan
because
i want to save the drippings in the
blood i'm going to add that into
the sauce that we make it's going to be
really really really really good
so now i'm adding the rest of the short
ribs
and if you guys have any pieces with fat
on them make sure you guys stare with
the fat side down
so you render all that fat out honestly
just going to throw them all in there
at this point these pieces
i'm gonna add just a little bit more oil
to this all right y'all so now that we
have browned our short ribs i'm going to
add our onions
to this pot
[Music]
gonna sweat these down a little bit i
want to make sure that i'm like scraping
the bottom of the pot
sometimes it'll help if you have a towel
to hold the pot so you're not like
burning your hands
[Music]
so as you see the fawn has lightly
colored the onions they look a little
bit brown like they've been
sitting in this pot for a while but
that's just the flavor from the fond
releasing into the onions now i'm gonna
go ahead
and add the celery
and the carrots at the same time because
we don't have any time
to waste we try to eat some short ribs
so
mix it up make sure you guys scrape down
the sides
i personally like to add my herbs in
with my mirepoix some people like to add
it
in when they're when they add the liquid
but i like to make sure i cook off
a little bit of the thyme with the
mirepoix because it brings a nice flavor
to it versus just having it in there by
itself
so i'm just going to sprig a few
leaves into our mix here and mix it up
make it super aromatic at this point i'm
going to go ahead i'm going to add the
garlic
inside the pot so garlic goes in
it's going down so the garlic is in here
my mouth is salivating i'm going to add
our ginger next
fresh ginger and then i'm going to go
ahead
and add our lemongrass
so lemongrass is kind of intimidating to
work with sometimes because
people think it's like how am i supposed
to use this but if you use this you guys
want to make sure you guys beat it up
really really well to break the fibers
down before you guys chop it
and it's gonna be amazing so i'm gonna
go ahead and add
the lemongrass in now
our baby hairs are sweating we need to
brush some edges back one more time
all right so now we're going to deglaze
the pan
with red wine if you guys are cooking
over open fire you guys want to make
sure that the
flame is low before you guys add the
wine because then goes your edges and
your eyelashes and your baby hairs and
all that stuff
you want to catch on fire so add the
wine cook it down for about two minutes
and then we're gonna add the rest of the
ingredients
and then i'm gonna add our stock
in goes the soy sauce
soy sauce and then the key secret
ingredient
plum sauce yeah i don't know what i went
through to get this plum sauce all right
this is this is really gonna make or
break this dish
so plum sauce goes in i'm gonna mix it
up
and then i'm to add the short ribs
back to the braising liquid so
you want to just nestle everything in
here get them close together
one happy short rib family the short
ribs are in the braising liquid
i'm gonna add the blood from the short
ribs don't forget to do that i know that
sounds crazy at the blood but trust me
that's fine it's gonna be great so
now is a good time for me to add a few
sprigs of parsley
so now after i add the aromatics to the
top i'm going to pop the lid on
and then i'm going to cook it for about
an hour until it gets tender you want to
make sure
when you stick a fork in there it falls
apart it's going to be amazing
so now that it's bubbling the short ribs
are cooking i'm going to go ahead and
pop the bay leaf
inside here and now i'm going to pop
this in the oven at 325 degrees for
about an
hour which gives you the perfect amount
of time to get up and go vote
all right guys now that i just came back
from voting and
skimming my short ribs i am going to
check my short ribs out while they were
in the oven i skimmed all the fat off of
them and as you can see the short ribs
are so tender and so juicy so what i'm
gonna do
next is i'm going to take
some of the veggies and the braising
liquid and i'm gonna pop it into a
blender
and make sure you guys get all of that
mirepoix that has cooked down and it's
nice and translucent
we're going to blend about half of this
and then we're gonna add it
back into the pot what this is gonna do
is thicken
up our sauce
and at this point honestly you can go
ahead and take the bay leaves out
so i'm going to pop this on make sure
you guys put the lid on it because this
is hot liquid i don't want you guys to
make a mess or
accidentally burn yourself so i'm going
to go ahead and pulse this
and then i'm going to transfer what we
pulsed into the pot so
it's going to thicken up the sauce
i'm going to give it a mix
it'll be okay i'm hungry i'm trying to
get all my presidency swag i'm trying to
be
visualizing myself in the white house so
i'm gonna go ahead and plate this
i have my bowls here and i'm gonna grab
a few short ribs
okay next i'm going to
ladle some of the braising liquid
in here so it's going to be kind of like
a soup we have like this braised
beautiful short rib stew so now that the
ribs and the stew are in the bowl i'm
just going to chop up some fresh parsley
doesn't have to be too fine nothing too
crazy
just chop it down and add a little bit
of fresh parsley on top
a few little leaves of thyme because we
love it
and then i'm going to take our
horseradish i'm going to shave it down
just a little bit
and this is really what's going to set
off our beautiful short ribs
so i'm going to add a little bit of
horseradish right on top
and crack pepper just for funsies
a little pinch of salt and there we have
it
obesity so chef breezy is actually going
to come over here and taste these
obesity
short ribs just because that works
perfectly right
so hi everyone i'm chef breezy from the
tasty kitchen i am
super excited this smells phenomenal tea
did her
thing with this recipe so i'm just going
to dive right in
see if goldilocks had this as her first
bowl there would have been no need
to go searching for more i see why my
man's back here love this dish so
much after this two bites i feel so
special right now like this is the type
of bowl like this is a treat show self
meal
and i feel very treated i'm feeling
special i'm feeling like michelle's
about to come out and have me a napkin
and just help me pat down
because my mouth is just salivating with
each bite it is seriously
bravo bravo kudos to you my man thank
you chef t
for preparing this thank you obzi for
the recommendation
i'm gonna go find a corner and go enjoy
the rest of this
and go make sure my register all right
y'all
breezy's at it banging i'm telling you
right now
bang it make sure you guys tune in next
time for some more presidential bites
and don't forget to vote in that song
people say that right
[Music]